Germany's customs service says it has seized 4.5 tons of cocaine,...
...the country's largest ever, with an estimated street value of 1.1 billion dollars.
Rwanda has denied claims by the Democratic Republic of Congo...
...that it closed its borders over Ebola fears...
...and emphasized that the closure is due to a technical issue.
In Croatia, a man shot and killed six people, including a 10-year-old child,...
...in the capital, Zagreb, before killing himself,...
...in what Croatian police described as domestic violence.
In India, Indian Health Minister Harsh Vardhan...
...met the protesting doctors in the capital, New Delhi,...
...and appealed to them to end their protest over a National Medical Commission Bill...
...that they say will hurt medical studies and services.
Finally, Saudi Arabia enacted new laws that loosen restrictions on women...
...by allowing all citizens to apply for a passport and travel freely,...
...ending a long-standing guardianship policy...
...that has controlled women's freedom of movement.